-President Trump
is still refusing
to accept his loss
in the November election
and now virtually
the entire Republican Party
is in lockstep behind him as he
tries to invalidate the results
and overthrow the democratically
elected government.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Well, it was fun
for a couple of days, wasn't it?
It's like we all sat through
a long, boring wedding,
and we finally got to drink
and dance our hearts out,
and then they stop the music
for one more speech
from the racist grandpa.
"I remembered something else
about Korea."
Donald Trump
in the Republican Party
are not only refusing to concede
a presidential election,
they clearly
and decisively lost,
they're acting as if Trump will
remain in office
despite the will of the people.
The Trump White House
is moving forward
with its budget proposal
for next year,
vetting new hires for
a second term,
firing officials
at the Pentagon
and replacing them
with unqualified yes-men,
authorizing Justice Department
investigations
of non-existent voter fraud,
and saying stuff like this.
-Is the State Department
currently preparing to engage
with the Biden transition team,
and if not,
at what point does a delay
hamper a smooth transition
or pose a risk
to national security?
-There will be
a smooth transition
to a second Trump
administration.
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Mock chuckle ]
A hilarious joke about the
President of the United States
actively trying to overthrow
his democratically elected
successor.
I'm sorry, but are we all sure
he was joking?
Mike Pompeo has all the charm
and comedic timing
of a divorced gym
teacher meeting
his girlfriend's son
for the first time.
"Hey, Tyler,
come on, pull my finger.
Come on, pull it."
"Hey, I'm 26, bro."
"Just pull it."
"All right, fine. Oh!"
"Hmm, I [bleep] my pants.
Ahh...
I'm gonna go change my pants."
Honestly, I don't know
if it was a joke or not,
but either way I'm gonna
go out on a limb
and say if you're
the Secretary of State,
maybe don't joke
about a possible coup.
That's one of those
no-joking jobs,
you know, like Army
drill sergeant or oncologist.
"Well, Dave, I'm looking at
your X-ray and it's bad news.
You're going to spend about
40 more years with your wife."
"You can take them with you."
The truth is it's clear
and unavoidable.
Joe Biden is the president-elect
of the United States
based on a decisive win
in last week's election.
And that's not going to change
no matter how many ballots
Republicans challenge.
Incidentally,
Trump is currently winning
North Carolina,
which accepts mail-in ballots
nine days after the election
as long as they were postmarked
by election day and oddly,
I don't hear any Republicans
whining about fraud.
The margins in states Biden won
are too large
for Trump to overcome,
even if they did find an
isolated case of actual fraud,
which they haven't
because it doesn't exist.
Just take
Maricopa County in Arizona.
After a week
of baselessly claiming fraud
and suggesting Trump could
end up winning the state,
Trump's legal team
has challenged a grand total
of 180 rejected ballots.
Biden leads in Arizona
by 14,746 votes.
It's like the Jets
kicking a field goal down
42 points after the game
is already over.
"Coach, send me out there
for the fifth quarter."
"There are only four quarters."
"Um, then why isn't a quarter
worth four cents, Coach?"
They can't provide any proof
at all that there was any fraud
let alone widespread
systemic fraud on the scale
required to overturn
the election results
because there wasn't any.
Investigations by both
the "New York Times" and AP
have confirmed that.
The Trump team's lies
are so transparent,
even Fox News cut away from
one of their press conferences.
-You are welcoming fraud and you
are welcoming illegal voting.
We want every legal vote
to be counted
and we want every
illegal vote to be --
-Whoa, whoa, whoa, I just think
we have to be very clear
that she's charging -- the other
side is welcoming fraud
and welcoming illegal voting.
Unless she has more details
to back that up,
I can't in good countenance
continue showing you this.
-Man, it's rough when your most
sycophantic supporters bail.
That was like watching
Smithers say,
"Shut the [bleep] up old, man!"
It's like the National Zoo
cutting away from the panda cam
because the sex
is getting to graphic.
"Okay, they're humping.
That's fine.
Oh, and now they're --
Oh, my God.
Kevin,
what position is that?"
"I think that's called
standing wheelbarrow."
"Okay, cut the feed.
Cut the feed."
Kids are watching!
Cut the feed!"
By the way, in that same
press conference,
a reporter asked White House
Press Secretary
Kayleigh McEnany,
who incidentally gets paid
with your tax dollars to show up
and lie at Trump
campaign events,
a very simple,
straightforward question --
"Do you know for a fact
that there were
fraudulent votes cast?"
This will not shock you.
She did not answer.
-Look, what we are
asking for here is patience.
-So all you're saying
is you need a little patience?
Thanks, Guns 'N Rose.
You swore that would work,
Shoemaker.
-I said...?
-And I'm sorry.
Donald Trump wants patience?
The least patient man
on the face of the Earth?
The guy who literally shoved
his way
to the front of a group
of NATO leaders
like a bridesmaid trying
to catch a bouquet at a wedding?
"You already have a boyfriend,
Janet.
Let me have this."
A man so patient he tried
to close his umbrella once
and then just left it
on the stairs to the plane?
[ As Melania ] "Donald,
where is your umbrella?"
"Uh, Antifa took it?"
"Again?!"
"They're out to get me, Mel!"
These ghouls have had a week
since the election
to prove their voter fraud
bull [bleep]
and all they can do
is ask for patience.
This is like if you came home
late from work
with lipstick on your collar
and your wife asked,
"Are you having an affair?"
And you said, "Look I can get
you a cover story tomorrow,
but right now I am dead tired
due to some very strenuous
extramarital sex."
And every time
they do mention something
that sounds vaguely nefarious
like dead people
registered to vote
or backdating ballots
or whatever,
it always turns out
to have a very simple
and innocent explanation.
In Pennsylvania,
a postal worker admitted
he fabricated claims
of ballot tampering
and recanted them,
or how about Nevada,
where the Trump campaign
is challenging
3,000 ballots cast by people
they claimed moved
to another state,
making them ineligible to vote?
Well, it sounds bad, right?
Well, it turns out
there's a different explanation.
According to
the "Wall Street Journal,"
"Service members
who have legally voted in Nevada
after being transferred
elsewhere."
That's right, Trump and the GOP
are trying to get
thousands of ballots cast by
service members thrown out
because they legally voted
in Nevada
and then were transferred
elsewhere."
Because that's what happens
when you're in the military.
In just four years, the GOP has
gone from "support the troops"
to disenfranchise the troops --
on Veterans Day, no less.
Bravo.
What's on tap for Groundhog Day?
Are you going to pour gasoline
into Punxsutawney Phil's
burrow?
"I say how much winter is left.
Who's got a match?"
Trump promised for months
that this is exactly
how he'd react if he lost
and now he's doing it
and shredding American democracy
in the process.
If anything,
this might be the first time
he's delivering on
what he promised.
Let's not forget in 2016
he also said he wouldn't accept
the election results either.
So unlike his pledge
to build a wall
that Mexico pays for,
that we'd win so much
we'd get sick of winning,
that coronavirus would go away
when the weather got warmer,
in this case,
Trump has kept his word
to the American people
about not accepting the word
of the American people.
If a guy walks into a party
and says,
"I cannot promise that
I won't go through
your wife's underwear,"
and you later catch him
elbows deep in her stretch silk,
eyes closed,
mouth hanging open,
saying, "Love that
dryer sheet smell,"
the fault kind of lies on you
for not immediately
kicking him out
when he said the first thing.
Sore winners
really make good losers.
You might remember
that in 2016,
Trump made the absolutely
ludicrous, unhinged claimed
that 3 to 5 million voted
illegally in that election,
which he won, and which
Hillary conceded the next day.
Trump even promised
an investigation
to prove that he was right.
-If you look
at voter registration,
you look at the dead people
that are registered to vote
who vote, you look at people
that are registered
in two states,
you look at all of these
different things
that are happening
with registration,
you take a look
at those registration for--
you're going to find --
and we're going to do
an investigation on it.
-But 3 to 5 million
illegal votes?
-Well, we're going to
find out,
but it could very well
be that much.
-When you say, in your opinion,
millions of illegal votes,
that is something
that is extremely fundamental
to our functioning democracy,
a fair and free election.
-Sure. Sure.
-You say you're going to launch
an investigation into this.
-Sure, done.
-So you've launched
an investigation?
-We're going to launch
an investigation to find out.
-Surprise --
he did not find out.
Trump would be the worst
private investigator.
"Sure, doll, I'll help you
find your husband.
Uh...
Is that him, down there
under that streetlamp?
No?
Well, I'm out of ideas."
When this is over,
he should star in
a British
detective series called,
I don't know,
"The Trumpledown Mysteries,"
and every episode
would be him slowly revealing
he's done
No investigating.
"Have you deduced who the killer
is, Inspector Trumpledown?"
"Uh, I'm getting close.
Closer every day.
Hearing some very, very bad
things about the butler.
Oh, we don't like the butler,
do we, folks?
But we're probably, possibly
going to have an answer soon
because one thing we can
all agree on --
the countess is dead --
or not."
This is the same stunt
Trump's been pulling for years.
Remember when he built
his entire political career
on the racist conspiracy theory
that the first black president
wasn't born in the US?
You know,
the one that rocketed him
to stardom
with Republican voters
because he's not a unique
figure in history,
but a perfect emblem
of the racism
and depravity of the modern
conservative movement?
Well, anyway, he pretended
he was doing the same
dumb investigative work
back then too.
-He may not have been born
in this country,
and I'll tell you what,
three weeks ago
I thought he was born
in this country.
Right now
I have some real doubts.
I have people that actually
have been studying it
and they cannot believe what
they're finding.
-You have people now
down there searching?
-Absolutely.
-I mean, in Hawaii?
-Absolutely. And they cannot
believe what they're finding.
-Obviously he did not send
investigators down to Hawaii
because you have to pay
investigators.
But if you did, I bet that would
have been a plum gig --
a world-renowned idiot
sends you
on an all-expenses-paid
trip to Hawaii
to investigate
a racist conspiracy theory
you know is bull [bleep],
and all you have to do
is call him up and say,
"Uh, yeah. No, we're finding
a lot of stuff down here.
No, no, no,
you wouldn't believe it.
Hey, can I get another Mai Tai,
and this time can I get a,
I don't know, inside a pineapple
with a little umbrella?
Thank you.
Anyway, yeah, Donald.
We're finding
lots of proof down here.
We're going to need
some more money and maybe a...
Maybe a masseuse?"
This is the same scam
Trump's been running
for years, and every time
Republicans and their voters
eat it up.
For example, Trump actually went
through with that dumb threat
to investigate
voter fraud in 2016
and put together a commission
that was so unsuccessful,
they had to disband it
after finding nothing.
The commission was led by
Kris Kobach,
the former Kansas
Secretary of State,
who found so little proof
of voter fraud,
he got humiliated in
a disastrous interview on CNN.
-We have about 3 million people
who are registered
in more than one state,
and that's not a crime.
-Right, including --
-That's just an administrative
bookkeeping --
-Including the president's
son-in-law,
including the president's
Treasury Secretary.
-Exactly.
Yeah, and many of your viewers
are probably registered
in more than one state.
But what is a crime is
if you actually vote
in both of those states
or in more than two states.
-Of course it's a crime.
-And every --
-But where is the evidence
of this widespread,
rampant
millions of people voting?
If it had happened,
why haven't we seen it?
-We've already filed nine cases.
-From the notes that I saw,
you have nine cases.
-And we have six guilty pleas.
-Right, six guilty pleas,
one dismissed,
two pending --
that's as January 25th.
Nine cases does not rampant
widespread voter fraud make.
And -- and the nine cases
are just the ones
at the top of the list.
One of the interesting
things we found
in prosecuting
this crime in Kansas
is that both Republicans
and Democrats do it.
-These guys are such
bumbling morons
they went from claiming
that there were
3 to 5 million illegal votes,
all of them for Democrats,
to there were six guilty pleas
and some of them were
Republicans.
It's like an episode
of "Law & Order" that starts
with a jogger
finding a body in the park
and ends with a coroner's report
that says, "He was just sleeping
and now he's pissed
and he's a lawyer
and he's suing us."
There's a common through line
from birtherism
to lies about voter fraud.
Republicans
don't see their opponents
as legitimate,
and they don't accept
the outcomes
of democratic elections.
That's why they claimed
the first black president
wasn't born here
and that mail ballots
are somehow fraudulent
or that a secret army
of dead people rose up
from their graves,
voted in this election,
and then held
a press conference
in front
of a landscaping company.
[ As Rudy ]
"Thanks for coming, everyone.
It's getting late,
so I better scoot on over
to the cremation center."
The Republican Party's
an authoritarian movement
that is opposed to democracy
and does not see victories
by their political opponents
as legitimate.
They believe they are
the only ones entitled
to wield power regardless
of what voters actually want.
Maybe it's just me,
but I'm not sure we can have
a functioning democracy
if one side refuses to accept
the results whenever they lose.
And even if this specific
coup attempt doesn't work,
that's not like good news.
Someone tries to rob a bank
but gives up because
he can't crack the safe,
you install
new security measures
to stop them
from doing it again.
You don't just wave goodbye
and say "No harm, no foul.
Take care, buddy.
Come back, you know,
if you want to open
a checking account."
Suffice to say,
it's not a good situation
when you have
one political party
committed to democracy
no matter the outcome,
and the other opposed
to democracy at all costs.
Even if this ridiculous
coup attempt fails,
it doesn't bode well
for the future,
which is why we need
bold systemic reforms
to empower everyone to vote
and honor
what the majority
of voters actually want,
like abolishing
the electoral college
and fixing the Voting Rights
Act, among other things.
These should be no-brainers.
If we had a healthy
functioning political system,
both parties would react to
these ideas by saying...
-Sure, done.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching
this online,
you can hit the "Donate" button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.